recently it was brought to my attention
that in Japan get this in Japan there's
a super popular manga an anime character
named Detective Conan and this is a huge
thing Detective Conan there he is
get this list oh man he's a man who's
trapped in a child's body and solves
crimes man trapped in a child's body
Conan hello okay think about it
detective conan is clearly a ripoff all
right and I looked into it detective
conan was created a year after I went on
the air in 1993 afterwards and check it
out
he has distinctive hair as do I he
always wears a suit as do I again man
trapped in a child's body plus if that's
not enough this is a picture of me as a
schoolboy and I don't know if you see
any oh yes oh my god exactly that's how
I Drive and I solve crime I solved a lot
of crimes back then anyway detective
conan is so popular in japan
apparently it's huge one of the biggest
things going in Japan they are now have
Conan live-action movies they have Conan
cafes and this really blew my mind
there's an actual city I am NOT making
this up
Kukui that's been renamed Conan town if
they have a city named Conan town yes
and guess what clearly
no you shouldn't be applauding cuz I'm
getting screwed clearly someone's been
making a ton of money off the Asian
version of me for 24 years so the other
night after I find out about this you
know this Andy I went on TV and I asked
Japan I thought it was reasonable to pay
me 3 trillion yen to make this whole
unpleasant controversy go away and guess
what today I got a reply on the cone
intentness is real on the Conan town
Facebook page their mayor thanked me for
mentioning their city and then said if
you want the money come visit Conan town
[Music]
that's three trillion yen Wow
I think that works up to eight hundred
dollars or something I don't have a look
into it
it's pretty good it's pretty good okay
well your honor I am very pleased you've
invited me to collect my money at Conan
town however before I visit Conan town I
have just a few modest demands one I
want a building named after me Conan
Town already has a train station and an
airport named after Detective Conan so I
want you to change the name of your
town's most popular coin laundry that
you have right now to American Conan's
fluffle Hall that's what I want and I
command it I want that okay I want it
second second
I want a key to the city okay it's
called Conan town I want a key to the
city and not only that I want the key to
the homes of everyone in a 20-mile radio
yeah and finally if you really want me
to come you'll change the hair on your
iconic statue of Detective Conan to
something just a little more flattering
you've got to do that you've got to make
a you all that
plus three trillion yen you owe me and
I'm on my way
[Applause]
you